Bulls to win bound gomes la défense take
it away by wind al Carter jr. and on the
exit interview last year Fred Hoiberg as
the Pacers come the other way with
Bogdanovich blocked by partner
33:34 here comes Simmons the doctor way
by Carter nice defensive play by the
rookie I'm Judy and you know once again
off that phase regime
[Applause]
for you Bullock thinks he has a layup no
soup for you get that out of here now
it's forced in by why I called it
adjusted holidays gotta keep cutting you
stopped on that play that's right I do
that oh let me see it for you and
Charlotte and watch the rookie make
himself available you see the rotation
over there not even paying attention to
their home Dale
with a shovel slow to Carter shy pocket
five over land is going finished by the
look at this tough break for him it's
the hand in the passing lane the
turnover on young here's Levine Endicott
ER no listen that one comes into block
square and one a guy can be hot Neal you
give him that he's shooting the ball
extremely well but it's something there
you go but at some point you've got to
take it personal down the floor and get
to the spots that he wants if Steph
Curry comes down and sets a screen on me
and I'm Garden klay Thompson sent drop
down to win tell Carter the rookie backs
turns up string cheese
that was a strong move on when Dale
what's in the house free cheese we'll be
right back
the Bison minutes here are good good cut
that time by lean the shoulder-in has a
drive right there
55% old at the steel steel in his skull
are cheeky a cappella
[Applause]
rookie hands it back to pain in the
traffic shovel with the quarter and he
draws the final scores anyway
top basket right there to win Dale
Carter mr. Carter vu Neil funk close-up
shot fake Turner goes up strong enough
position he'll [ __ ] I mean there's oh
man tall wrinkles yeah it was a terrific
you don't be late you've seen the
regular season now so you got his legs
underneath had it knocked away got it
back watch him here he's gonna hustle
back into the plate get in position to
help his teammates here goes up no suit
for you there's no rebound for went out
Carter back down to a slight exact
Levine and he scores offensive rebound a
second-chance opportunity for the Bulls
it's almost like he has not seen a
double team so
[Applause]
mr. Potter to you first seven point of
the third quarter he's playing with a
lot of confidence
hey leaves it off a wet room there you
go good dish right there when you get
you some stops you want him to let you
back in the game going up high incoming
now are the big fella throw it up and
I'll go get Carter going right back at
him good move and the rookie that time
with the threat because right here boom
eyebrow fake goes right by him strong
move by the rookie finishing with the
left
up and under and one to be TT
[Applause]
to the basket it's a grown man he's only
19
he's trouble I'll tell you what
mark sent our TV a can old bodies him
fake see me that the Windex man and are
taking five percentage shots that's what
you want to see you see guys this jacket
will get out their way got that to
Wendell Carter
Blake beam into the lane and then the
little flip for the assist to went down
[Music]
bounce for the rookie Collin Sexton
bounce to Thompson bullies his way to
block by let bail give the ass now - off
the window harder screen the back to
window based on that was a trip off it
was the pass near they tried to get
earlier when he threw it away
Gossage Zack circles to the top back to
win Del Rio and window doesn't mr. Smith
[Music]
[Applause]
oscar's block here no suit for you
dodges I know it's cold outside you not
getting any sleep tonight but being on
the run about stuff Parker drives block
loose picked up
[Music]
attending his late grandfather's
memorial service came back on Sunday and
the loss at Portland for 21 points such
you're here there's Wendell Carter jr.
throwing it down
Chandler Hutchison got cut off holiday
into a tight window a fantastic partner
and if they can do that more right there
pravin wheels dishes are cheesy action
owned by a porter junior to the lefty
hook it's good to mom
how's the footwork in the touch rebound
to win del now pay bounced inside a good
job of running the floor that time a
pump fake that driving missed the dunk a
good challenge by Justin holiday there
Thomas how can he pile kicks it to the
corner ties the faith about sands not
the way it stolen good defense by the
gold Parker on the run wheels right by I
was better now that Jimmy's not here
this is amazing this is an all-star
caliber player Athena this went down
goes up scores his first team's third
each team with three team fouls
6:04 left to play for that--for to Zack
but went down all arts gonna fake and a
shot with the Wildcat fake fake the
handoff and pull up for help Drummond's
back in he's matched up with him
timer waiting that's another on high
that's a nice move good shot blocker got
that shot over him remarketing there's
two good pieces to have Carter attacking
drawn one hanging hit all the young
fella taking the big boy to school look
at me you can think got a bounce to his
step right now and see this is only done
and they'll plant a bunch of young
players farter one of those young line
thank you off the glass I've got a [ __ ]
in attack mode
give me that 2:01 break the B rises up
and throws it down he goes in I know
it's cold outside but there's no soup
for you he blocks it starts the
fast-break there give Jimmy
and they're off and running and zach
lavine
come fly with me
the beam nice feed inside Carter - hey
hey high school
if it's a game is a lot better than what
it was when he first came in the lead
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Tiffin
we feel Tiger
[Music]
[Applause]
at 6:00 left quickly down to wit del
turns into the governor's goal
mr. Potter hi Chris done right here
seasons got the advantage I watch the
double come right there but he still was
able to get through that breakaway
that's just his second field right here
there he is right here roll into the
basket and a nice strong extension on
the hook shot and it got a shot blocker
yeah he got it up there quickly before
cauley-stein could route got a post up
Carter right now on bomb a couple of
rookies matched up and win del Carter
wins that battle with so much confidence
we talked about in the open where he's
an average of 30 oh and there's a
terrific pass and win del just flushed
it
[Music]
good job by Chris dawn roving the
defense
inside three
with Russell wasa hip just a moment ago
there's arch good don't be late here at
Allen in tonight and watch right here
when Dell is pounds one down today
stutter steps baseline able to go back
and get it before he comes off done man
there's nice for what yell inside says
as he does die running in short my dolls
are to clean up
eight and on done personal foul number
three though he has three back and say
rebound the basketball bell inside he
suddenly come to life and they're
looking for know with for those are the
two governments
[Music]
it's very sentence in the foul trouble
it kind of takes him out of it other
things that he likes to do get out the
way nice wall to the rim so the black on
one end the slam on the other for window
Carter for last game he's always just
standing at the three-point line and
setting screens you've got to use his
athleticism for coming out of number 84
only the second ever in the NBA to wear
that one I know the other there you know
or for Carter Chris Weber for a brief
moment the marketing with his 11th
rebound hey Carter running right to the
round that's that's where to keep easier
I've written down the fourth beat on the
play
Holliday cross-court to Zach Lavine
working it inside the window Carter jr.
patiently trying to go against the roll
till hi it's good comes a nice strong
move now watch this move right here
patience crab dribble fake baseline will
come back with a jump hook walk it's
done shovels it down
went down there you go done the corner
[Music]
hustle right there by wind ale and some
Windex we know cleaning the glass comes
in gets inside position goes up I'll
turn it looked like Myles Turner just
thought that ball was gonna fall to him
so I didn't even jump for it and when L
took advantage
[Applause]
they was turn fell down Sabonis to the
corner
[Applause]
way off Italian what
more active tonight areas the block my
name's had some wide open man he's old
four three done the drive and then the
passed away Bell nice play
Fidel does that exact okay today felt
love dumps and right now the Bulls are
doing a good job of finding win Dale
Carter on the dive cuts cleaner Blakeney
a driving a kick
Archie underneath at that clover more
and dance the puppet at Collins to file
and he's gonna find him at the last
second going up to shoot it Oh big man
come over drop it off to my big man drop
back to window Carter what dribble and
about that's it thanks took hi to
shooting foul still for Zack Lavine
there's went he'll slit right between
two defenders marking it for three that
won't go
slice young live versus old line young
line winner oh wow what's up you guys
this Taylor Brooks with bleacher report
make sure that you subscribe for some
more video content